sont donc pas révoquer ce plan contre
les violences conjugales dans le figaro
de ce matin marlène schiappa on avait
déjà dévoilé les grandes lignes
le premier ministre a annoncé ces
mesures à l'issue d'une concertation
qu'on a appelé un grenelle et voici en
résumé quelques mesures choc de ce plan
nous allons lancer un appel à projet
pour que deux centres de prise en charge
des hommes violents voit le jour dans
chaque région créeront également d'ici
2021 80 postes supplémentaires
d'intervenants sociaux dans les
commissariats et les brigades
nous devons lorsque cela peut sauver des
vies offrir la possibilité aux médecins
de déroger au secret médical au
gouvernement consacrera l'année
prochaine plus d'un milliard d'euros à
l'ensemble des actions en matière
d'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
dont cadre de cette somme
nous désirons 360 millions à la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
mathilde branca ya beaucoup de mesures
dans ce plan est ce que ce sont les
bonnes a votre avis beaucoup de mesures
oui tout à fait il y en a une
cinquantaine je crois de mémoire donc
plus de 13 qui sont purement
législatives et juridiques les bonnes en
tout cas ce que je trouve c'est ce plan
il est quand même assez équilibré parce
que il plan il prend quand même en
compte trois dimensions très importante
il ya une chanson qui a pas du tout été
évoquée dans les exemples qui sont
données là c'est la dimension éducative
qui à mon avis est la base et le fond
pour éradiquer les les violences
conjugales les violences faites aux
femmes les violences faites aux hommes
c'est parce qu'il ya des hommes qui sont
victimes de violences conjugales il faut
le rappeler de manière générale en tout
cas en 2018 c'était voilà 121 féminicide
et 28 homme mort sous les coups de leur
séjour un voile un casque ou tavenaux
ritter je corrige aussitôt tout à fait
mais voilà donc il ya une toute une
partie l'éducation qui est quand même à
mon avis la base d'autant plus que
l'éducation à l'égalité femmes hommes
elle va s'attaquer aussi à la société
patriarcale à la notion de société
patriarcale ce qui je pense en fait est
la base pour le futur de nos générations
on s'est créé un lien entre ce qui était
patriarcale
la place du père et les violences
conjugales quand on pousse très très
très très loin quand il ya une réaction
de violence d'un dominant vis-à-vis d'un
dominé puisque c'est ainsi que laisse la
société a longtemps mis les relations
entre les femmes et les hommes
quand c'est une situation de violence
c'est souvent qu'on est à l'extrême
limite qu'on ne sait plus quoi faire
d'autre donc c'est probablement qu'on
est au bout avant de passer à l'étape
d'après savoir une véritable égalité il
ya aujourd'hui des problèmes d'égalité
femmes hommes dans notre pays c'est une
réalité et les violences conjugales sont
un de ces marqueurs quand on voit les
proportions entre les violences faites
aux hommes par rapport aux violences
faites aux femmes au sein des couples on
voit que c'est que ça reste un marqueur
il ya le deuxième pan qui est le dire
elle pas majoritaires sur lequel il ya
le plus de mesures c'est l'assistance
aux victimes
ça c'était vraiment la partie
urgentissime de ce qu'il fallait faire
donc il ya des choses aussi très
intéressant qui sont fait dedans et puis
la partie sur le suivi des des des
actions de ceux qui font de ceux qui
crient qu'ils font de la violence
conjugale
c'est aussi c'est aussi primordial ce
qu'on peut déplorer c'est les montants
alloués aujourd'hui le l'observatoire
des violences faites aux femmes
il a mon île à il a estimé qu'il y avait
aujourd'hui 220 mille femmes qui sont
victimes de violence conjugale et on
parle de 750 places de logements
d'urgence
c'est les proportions sont allés bonne
ont néanmoins c'est un plan qui est long
on célébrait carbone qui est bonne quand
même mesure je pense renée fregosi je
rappelle parce qu'on n'a pas dit
aujourd'hui que vous avez été très jeune
engagée dans le mouvement féministe
c'est que ça me plaît beaucoup moins
sage et satisfecits non parce que je
trouve que c'est un éclairage
intéressant compte tenu de ce que vous
allez nous dire maintenant
oui je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
que mathilde viens de dire donc je je je
poursuivrai simplement je pense que la
violence faite aux femmes et notamment
les homicides sur les femmes relève de
cette conception de la possession de
l'autre
alors effectivement dans nos sociétés
enfin dans toutes les sociétés
d'ailleurs enfin sauf les gouaille
acquise
sont pas très nombreux les gouaille
acquise c'est s'aider des indiens des
basses terres et iodée la wii peuvent
avoir quatre marins bon mais mais mais
mais c'est exceptionnel donc toujours
est-il cette question justement de la
possession de l'autre dans le couple
monogamique ça c'est un vrai problème et
c'est très souvent justement lorsque la
femme s'en va veut s'en aller
quel va être tué donc les violences les
plus grandes se porte généralement sur
des femmes qui veulent se soustraire à
cette possession mais les femmes aussi
elles sont positives moi je suis
absolument contre le couple monogamique
donc je vais 10h et oui excusez moi mais
je pense que si si vous prenez les
chiffres justement c'est quand même dans
ce huit clos conjugal que ça se passe on
est enfermés dans un appartement et on
se tue toujours non non non non mais
lorsqu on sait qu on l a plupart du
temps à plus de 90% des fois dans son
appartement où on tourne en rond
vous avez également la question de
l'indépendance économique des femmes
55% des femmes qui sont assassinés par
leur mari ne travaille pas donc elles
sont soit dépendante économiquement mais
très souvent 46% des hommes ne
travaillent pas non plus d'ailleurs dans
ces cas de dôme incident
donc vous avez aussi la question sociale
bien sûr mais cette question de l'autre
m'appartient et donc je peux tout y
compris le tuer ça aussi ça doit être
travaillée mais évidemment ça c'est du
travail à long terme mais pour les
mesures
je suis absolument d'accord avec ce que
vous venez dire il fallait faire
l'urgence c'est effectivement s'occuper
des cas urgents et là il ya qu'elle ya
une avancée il faut le gouvernement en
fait ils assez contre les violences
faites aux femmes c'était de la question
du sur lefigaro.fr et vous êtes une
petite majorité 52% à considérer
que non et puis ce commentaire de
babineau qui va dans le sens de ce que
disait mathilde broquet il ya un grand
décalage entre l'ambition du
gouvernement est le budget alloué à
cette lutte andré bercoff votre point
par écouter d'abord il faudrait peut
être rappeler que quand on parle de
sport vous parliez mathilde de manque de
moyens par rapport aux chiffres etc
faut quand même rappeler c'est ça ou
j'adore edouard philippe
ce conte et montreur d'ours car une qui
fait ça son charme
il a parlé d'un milliard pour l'égalité
hommes femmes je veux dire quand même
que ce milliard les trois quarts sont
dédiés au togo au sénégal et au bénin
effectivement c'est très bien
t'encourager l'égalité hommes-femmes au
togo sénégal et je rappellerai que 282
millions pour la france
d'éducation je sais dans les écoles de
ces pays où l'égalité quand monsieur
edouard philippe parle du milliard on
aimerait qu'il dise comment est réparti
ce milliard je vous le dis enfin c'est
passé sont des chiffres officiels c'est
1,816 milliard d'euros 290 millions pour
la france
simplement peut-être c'est tout à fait
sulfureux mais de dire que peut-être
qu'il sera intéressant et c'est très
bien de s'occuper des élites hommes
femmes en afrique et ailleurs mais
peut-être qu'ils voudraient commencer
peut-être donner un peu plus à la france
deuxièmement et tous vous parliez de la
monogamie chère afrique d'abord j'aurais
vous je voudrais lui rendre hommage je
suis très content pour lui titre de son
livre elle est choisie le grand extrait
de marquis de sade dans la philosophie
dans le boudoir français encore un
effort si vous voulez rester république
est une femme qui suit le marquis de
sade me paraît pas absolument d'eau donc
alors apr est alors impressionnant a
révélé je reviens je reviens à ça il
faut quand même parler oui non non pas
la taxe mais je dirais très bien de
vitupérer le couple monogame
mais il ya certaines cultures et on le
sait aujourd'hui parce que ça on n'en
parle pas du tout il faut pas beaucoup
c'est que la femme est considérée comme
un sous-homme il ya des cultures
entières dans certains pays du monde on
le sait où la femme est considéré
littéralement comme un sous-homme que ce
soft plan juridique que ceux sur le plan
battez votre femme et s'est enfermé à la
maison elle est enfermé à la maison je
signale que parmi dans cette culture là
on favorise quand même la polygamie
donc il n'y a pas que la monogamie
essais les hommes qui sont s'offre au
sofa nouvelles-hébrides williams ce que
je veux dire c'est que n'oublions pas
quand même que noah ce qui m'a frappé
dans cette marche des femmes et c'était
formidable
je suis absolument pour mais ce côté
cette dimension là on soigne pas parce
que ça fait pas politiquement correct et
compagnie
merci et je vais passer bien sûr la
parole âgées qui c'est vrai mais moi
aussi j'ai été frappé alors je n'étais
pas à cette manifestation de ce week-end
mais en envoyant des images que parfois
mais c'était pas tous les slogans mais
on sentait une forme d'hostilité par
rapport aux sommes et peut-être est-ce
que par dolium bien eu pire vous n'avez
pas vu au milieu il y à une scène de
parodies sadomasochistes où une femme
est venue avec deux occasions ça oui la
provocation est l'époux était devant
tout le monde
les organisatrices quel professionnel
entre guillemets qui s'était introduit
dans la rue dominait lé voilà c'était
frapper on un jour ira sur les des
femmes qui étaient hostiles aux hommes
je pense que c'est dommage en fait de
voir dans ces situations là une espèce
de généralisation au tour des hommes il
faut bien individualiser les drames il
faut bien rappeler que ce sont certains
hommes les hommes de stéphane moulin qui
ont commis ça et ne pas en venir à une
société où on va accuser tous les hommes
d'être d'horribles personnes qui
viendront forcément faire du mal à leur
fin je pense que ça fait plus de mal à
la cause que de bien ça peut te fait
d'accord
avec vous je me permets de l'expliquer
tous ne se sentent pas concernés comme
tous ne se sentent pas exclus du sujet
moi personnellement remis le fait que
j'ai un prénom de fille donc j'ai droit
à un double temps de parole je suis très
engagé non pensez à qui exactement mais
je pense qu'il faut mettre en accusation
les hommes et renée fregosi et vous
aussi pardon mais comme ce soit aux
grands intellectuels puisque nous allons
les intellectuels d'un côté les autres
rappelleront ce qui a écrit françoise
héritier là dessus et je crois qu'elle a
tout expliqué et on a quand même un
problème depuis le début les hommes ne
possède pas les femmes les hommes ont un
problème avec une partie du genre humain
qui peut assurer la reproduction et ça
ça leur a toujours posé un problème et
donc le pouvoir qu'il fallait mettre là
dessus parce que c'était le pouvoir
qu'il fallait assurer pour la
reproduction de la race j'avoue ça veut
dire que en fait les hommes sont ils
peuvent pas avoir d'enfant françoise
héritier a expliqué que de vous étiez
c'est une sociologue c'est ça
sociologues anthropologues c'est la plus
grande spécialiste de la femme dans
toutes les sociétés elle a expliqué l a
prouvé par moult exemples dans tout un
tas suite et d'où venait le problème
originel et donc il est ancré lie ses
semelles qu'il faut démonter et les
hommes ont un problème là dedans et
c'est pas le fait que aujourd'hui dans
cette génération nous soyons des hommes
qu'on doit se sentir attaqué il faut se
dire nous sommes attaqués en tant que
race ou en tout cas partie de ce genre
humain et qui a été construit sur des
choses qui nous dépassent ça c'est un
premier point et je pense que ce travail
qui a été fait est extrêmement bien il
ya un point qui est bien dans ses plans
moi je trouve c'est aussi ce harcèlement
moral
217 femmes se sont suicidés du fait de
de harcèlement qui ont été sans doute
mis en place par les maris et ces
suicides sont la condition de ces choses
là et on ne les compte pas dans les
féminicides donc qu'on puisse
reconnaître ce point là et puis après le
dernier point au delà de tout ce que
vous avez
que je partage évidemment c'est briser
enfin cette espèce de tabou un peu
stupide qui consiste à penser que le
médecin doit absolument respecter un
secret aujourd'hui vous êtes la femme de
françois fillon vous devez alerté le
procureur de la république si vous êtes
fonctionnaire parce que vous avez
l'article 46 vous êtes commissaires aux
comptes et que carlos ghosn prend trop
d'argent dans la caisse
vous devez le révéler au procureur de la
république porté atteinte à l'intégrité
physique de quelqu'un passait devant un
médecin on essaye de nous expliquer
qu'il faudrait rester quelques il faudra
respecter quelques secrets que ce soit
et on arrive à s'en convaincre et je
suis persuadé qu'il ya des gens qui
seraient prêt à m'expliquer que ce que
je dis est stupide donc dans cette loi
se ce truc là je trouve est extrêmement
intéressant puis dernier point qu'on n'a
jamais dit rendons peut-être hommage à
celle sur laquelle on tape tout le temps
parce qu'elle a fait une chose au delà
de l'argent qu'elle a mis ses je pense
que l a balancé à sa manière le sujet
sur la table et je conclurai en disant
est ce qu'avec moi je parle de ma ligne
ça on n'a même pas besoin de la cité est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pensez que si
jamais je décroche mon téléphone et que
j'appelle madame catherine deneuve et je
lui dis bonjour madame
j'ai une tribune génial à faire pour
défendre les hommes est-ce que vous
laisse ignoriez non avec tout le débat
qui a eu sur ce sujet tout ce qu'on a
montré
le témoignage encore ce matin d'un
monsieur dont la fille a été tuée et qui
explique que depuis cinq ans le père qui
a tué sa fille a encore l'autorité
parentale sur l'enfant
eh bien je pense que catherine deneuve
se diraient non j'ai peut-être fait une
grosse connerie notre amie commune qu on
croit souvent
et dieu sait que j'adore et c'est la
seule fois je lui fais des reproches
sophie de menthon qui a aussi signé
cette tribune je pense que catherine
deneuve ne rechignerait pas si des noms
mais c'était pour défendre des attitudes
qui font qu à un moment on dit oui c'est
de la plaisanterie
oui on vous aide et à ses impressions de
place toi c moi j'ai grandi dans un
environnement militaire comme les femmes
j'ai grandi dans un environnement
quand on expliqua qu on faisait des
blagues aux femmes qui voulaient devenir
sapeur-pompier parce qu'elle ne pouvait
pas l'être et bien toute cette société
là elles engendraient des tas de petites
blagues et bien aujourd'hui elle a
permis marlène schiappa de faire avancer
le débat et je trouve ça très bien il
faut lire jacky isabello il va un peu
loin
vous savez le masochisme et la repentie
cement est serré manière avec db2 loto 6
6 1 alors il faut arrêter moi j'aime
bien françoise héritier et les héritages
et tout ce que vous voulez faut arrêter
de chosifier les gens il faut arrêter il
ya une tradition française qui a été
aussi l'impression de la galanterie la
solution de la séduction la région du
marivaudage avec au xviiie siècle des
maîtresses femmes il faut pas toujours
qui classe et tout chosifié deuxièmement
excusez moi vous parlez de catherine
deneuve
mais je veux dire on ne peut plus faire
aujourd'hui une seule blague on le
voulait la situation américaine
ce puritanisme absolument nocifs ou on
dit voilà on ne peut pas attention s'il
reçoit une femme dans son bureau il faut
laisser la porte ouverte si il faut
faire attention il faut baisser qu'est
ce que ça veut dire c'est pas ça moi je
condamne absolument toute contrainte
tout toute espèce de comment dire de
vulgarité et c'est enfin écouter ou son
on sait très bien ce qui se passe que ce
soit marine schiappa aux compagnies mais
a très longtemps on sait très bien que
si on va à la chapelle pajol ce qui se
passe on sait très bien ce qui se passe
dans un certain nombre de 2,2 lieu on
sait très bien qu'une femme ne peut pas
circuler en jupe bon mais mettre tout le
monde dans le même sac
jacky c'est pas possible pouvait pas
mettre tout le monde dans le même sac
nous avons été élevés nous avec un
respect dans le même sens y est dit que
les hommes endroit le mal doit se poser
des questions parce que les questions
sont très anciennes et se sont posés des
questions et ses blagues à deux francs
moi j'ai une fille vous en avez
peut-être oui j'ai pas envie qu'elle
finisse dans le bureau de quelqu'un qui
se permettra de lui faire des blagues
comme ça a été le cas depuis 4000 ans
j'ai pas envie d'endosser sa voie là
geraghty le broker réagit quand même à
entendre ça excusez moi vous ne savez
pas ce que c'est ah voilà les discours
que j'ai avec nombre de féministes
je suis un homme je ne sais pas ce que
ces jeunes vivent entre pas avant le
débat d'arrière garde
mais moi je dirige les entreprises de
vie 25 ans j'ai 90 % de femmes j'ai dû
protéger des femmes comme des clients je
peux vous en raconter des dizaines
planète puisque la boue par des gens qui
ont employé des gens là bas parce que je
suis un homme je ne sais pas ce que
c'est moi l'avons cherchée classe de
2nde arrêter de faire ça s'appelle ça
m'arrive tout le temps car je vais vous
dire je ne dis absolument pas que vous
n'avez pas le droit d'avoir une opinion
est que vous avez tout à fait une
opinion qui est construite qui est
réfléchie que ces terres etc
mais quand vous commencez à donner des
exemples de ce que ça fait pour une
femme
je vous dis juste vous ne savez pas ce
que ça fait et je vous dis que moi quand
je prends des réflexions et pour
beaucoup de femmes
on en a marre qu'on prenne la parole
pour et qu'on nous dise c'est comme si
vous devriez réagir ou c'est comme si
que vous devriez penser beaucoup de
femmes vous répondront je suis tout à
fait capable de répondre à fond mais
j'aurai beaucoup d'ailleurs on a
l'impression de l'avoir prise la parole
déjà depuis les années 70 nous les
vieilles et moi je n'ai je ne sais pas
ce que c'est que d'être insulté par un
homme et je ne sais pas ce que c'est que
avoir subi ce que vous vous subissez les
jeunes apparemment alors je ne sais pas
moi j'avais plutôt le sentiment
oui enfin j'avais plutôt le sentiment de
leur [ __ ] la trouille je vous dirais
franchement voilà
et là je pense que si je n'ai levens aux
petites filles en en faisant en sorte
que les mets qu'ils aient un petit peu
la trouille je pense que ça rétablir est
un peu les choses donc nous mlf on était
plutôt comme ça voilà donc on se
plaignait pas on n'était pas des pauvres
victimes a priori etc
new bond donc après ça suffit pas un
mois s'il ya trois gars qui me tombe
dessus avec des couteaux je peux pas
faire grand chose
voilà donc les en effet mais mais mais
mais mais cette histoire c'est vrai que
être un homme beau être une femme c'est
différent mais vous savez moi j'ai
toujours eu quand même un sentiment
d'étrangeté par rapport à la distinction
sexuelle ou sexuée
donc je trouve qu'aujourd'hui on en
rajoute un peu trop dans cette
différence il y aurait que des hommes
que des femmes non il n'y a pas que des
hommes que des femmes et je parle pas
seulement des transgenres
mais je veux dire on se sent pas
forcément une femme ou un homme
je ne sais pas voilà donc moi je ne sais
pas ce que c'est merci beaucoup
renée fregosi bas et à tous les cadres
pour ce débat parce